حسنًا ، اختتم الرئيس فولود مارزيلينسكي للتو
مؤتمرًا صحفيًا في
مؤتمر G7 في هيروشيما ، حيث
قالت مجموعة Wagner إنها استولت على
Buckmut الآن ، ينفي Zielinski أن
تكون المدينة في أيدي روسيا ، لقد أضاف
ذلك للتو وتحدث عنه ،
فلنستمع إليه.  ليس لدينا أسئلة بسيطة بعد الآن
وكذلك ليس لدينا إجابات بسيطة
لأن لدينا جار معقد للغاية وهو
مجرم وإرهابي
وأنيمي معقد ولكننا نواصل
القتال بفضل شجاعة
شعبنا ووريورز ووريورز  بفضل
نادينا ، نحن لا نرمي الناس
ليموتوا من أجلنا ، فالناس هو الكنز ،
هذا هو أهم شيء
لدينا وليس هناك سوء تفاهم ،
أنا أفهم بوضوح ما
يحدث ، ونحن جميعًا نفهم بوضوح سبب
أخذ كل ذلك.  مكان لا أستطيع أن
أشارككم فيه الآراء الفنية
لجيشنا لمحاربينا ولكن اعتبارًا من
اليوم يمكننا أن نرى أن الدولة التي
أكبر بعشرات المرات مما نحن عليه لا
يمكن أن تحتلنا لا تستطيع الفوز في هذه الحرب
ونحن نفهم ذلك أكثر قليلاً و
عندها سنكون سائدين
لهذا السبب نتصرف كيف
نتصرف مع التقييم المتاح
كان هناك بعض الأخطاء التكتيكية العسكرية على
سبيل المثال ويمكن محاصرة الناس
ثم يعرف كل الجيش ما يمكن أن
يحدث
كيف يمكننا خلق الوضع للأشخاص الذين
لا يتم أسرهم الآن
يقوم شعبنا بإنجاز مهمة مهمة جدًا هم
الآن ،
ولن أشارك أين بالضبط ، ولكن هناك
شهود لا يشغلها
الاتحاد الروسي حتى اليوم ،
لا يوجد تفسيران أو ثلاثة تفسيرات لهذه
الكلمات ،
شكرًا لك